welcome back the parade of Mischief
returns to downtown Summerlin this
weekend on this year's annual tradition
will be a little bit different hopefully
it'll still be equally spooky though
Candace Charles is live from downtown
Summerlin this morning looks pretty
terrifying behind you Candace good
morning
it is frightfully amazing as you can
imagine the ghouls are out the goblins
and of course a few werewolves but there
are some new things this year I'm doing
my hey larzinski with Downtown Summerlin
now I know this is one of the new floats
but here you have others tell us about
it we do we added three new flows to our
parade of mischief and we're so excited
to unveil it this Saturday at downtown
Summerlin awesome okay you gotta tell
people a little bit more about the
backstory of this amazing parade of
Mischief absolutely so we've always had
our holiday parade and who doesn't want
to celebrate Halloween all October long
so every Friday and Saturday in October
we've cast over 80 local kids and
they'll be out here performing in the
streets causing Mayhem and just
celebrating you know the fun Halloween
spirit awesome and they're performing
right now they're showing us their
skills I'm loving it absolutely okay
tell us when people can come on down
here and enjoy all of this yep so get on
down here early we recommend every
Friday and Saturday make a night of it
do some shopping some dinner get your
spot on the street the parade starts
promptly at seven o'clock and runs about
30 minutes awesome sounds like a great
time Haley thank you so much and I'll be
talking to some of these youngsters soon
so you guys will want to tune in and
check that out again the parade is on
Friday and Saturday all throughout
October first one is this Saturday at 7
p.m it's free and open to the public you
won't want to miss this it really is a
great time and of course I got you
covered with all the details on
eightnewsnow.com for now Candace Charles
8 News Now